Richard Sherman 99 overall 96 zone
covers 98 man coverage welcome to the 99
overall club Calvin he also has the 98
jump so I what up to Calvin he'll get
Peyton Manning 98 overall 99 awareness
99 short accuracy 96 medic you see but
86 throw power a lot of people come at
me and they think I'm some power trip
person and oh it's only my way that I
see the NFL like that that's what I'm
gonna make everybody in the world the
place man they got to think these
players are good these players stink my
name is Donnie Moore I'm an associate
producer and most importantly the
ratings are for the madden franchise it
starts out when I enter the video game
tournament at UCF student at ucf
political science major and happened to
come across this video game tournament
that was having our Student Union and it
was frenzy double a 2000 i believe
basically entered it i want it and they
offered me a job to test the game so i
started out testing this dude like 2001
and move my way up into the company and
probably started taking over for the
rosters in the ratings around 2003 i'm
proud to say that i am the first czar
dan patrick coin net on a radio show a
couple years ago for a madam pin and
that's stuck ever since in madden 15 we
have a 74 man maximum roster so 74 x 32
you're talking about 2200 players that's
not to mention the free agent all being
told about 2,600 players in madden that
were responsible for from a year-to-year
basis we have our rookies that come into
the league you got create them from
scratch and put a lot of tiny steps with
the first time we're seeing these guys
in the NFL in a video game I probably
took about 45 minutes solid just
documenting all of the different combine
staffs and the opinions and scouting
reports on clowny and all the top level
guys are probably getting about that
much attention for the veterans in the
league we do take a look during the
seasons course and even offseason we
look at the veteran players are they
trending up are they turning down are
they coming off of an ACL injury
somebody just looking like gangbusters
in training camp all those types of
things actually do factor into the
each week I'm spending anywhere from
about you know three days doing the
entire League's roster update sure I
mean the the thing you always get as a
ratings are is feedback from everywhere
and anywhere whether it be social media
Twitter's and Facebook's whether that be
the actual players themselves Harry
Rhodes he was mad about of all things
his throw power a safety he and nick
mangold basically took on to the YouTube
and competed he was mad that Nick mango
was rated 21 throw power and he was
ready I think 19 or something like two
points on they did it the whole contest
you know carry slung it I mean he slung
the ball pretty good and as a result of
that I bumped up Kerry Rhodes um no
power to I think 55 or no maybe 60 and I
will be the first person in line to get
changed something and say yeah Donnie
Moore got Victor Cruz way wrong last
year so we're really trying to capture
what's going on today with the player I
take it great pride in trying to be
accurate and stay as up-to-date as
possible to get it right I you know all
the criticism that goes along with it I
look at it as an opportunity to get it
right in next week's roster update